petit s'exprime ainsi c'est sans doute
la conférence de presse le plus tard le
soir que j'ai jamais eu
merci beaucoup je veux remercier le
peuple américain pour le soutien des
millions de personnes ont voté pour nous
ce soir est un groupe de personnes
essayent de deux empêcher ces gens
d'exprimer la voie et nous n'allons pas
l'accepter
j'aimerais remercier d'après mais adam
et le vice-président d'être là avec nous
[Applaudissements]
on s'apprête à une grande célébration à
une grande fête où tu tousses apprêtez à
1 à cette fête mais tout d'un coup ça a
été annulé les résultats étaient suit
pas et on était prêt à aller dehors et
fêter quelque chose de si beaux une
telle réussite les citoyens de ce pays
se sont exprimés dans des des normes
nombre on n'a jamais vu une chose
pareille et présente en floride à nos
floride and his y attendions à gagner
mais nous avons gagné de très loin nous
avons gagné remporté les cadeaux royaux
nous avons remporté le texas
[Applaudissements]
nous avons une marge de 2 700 mille
votes au texas et ils le prennent en
même temps quand on les calcule c'est
clair aussi que nous avons remporté la
géorgie 5.2 de marche dans cet état tant
qu' ils ne vont pas nous rattraper
nous avons presque vont porter la
caroline du nord nous avons avec une 4
poissons de match
avec 77 mille votes dont qui n'ont ils
ne vont pas nous rattraper et si on
s'intéresse à l'arizona
on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de mouvement
et quelqu'un a déclaré qu' on va le
remporter
peut-être que c'est le cas c'est
possible il ya eu beaucoup de voix
exprimées qui vont peut-être allé en
notre faveur
il s'agit de d'un territoire trompe et
donc on pourrait voir une réussite est
le monsieur qui a fait la déclaration a
dit que nous croyons que c'est probable
que qu'ils rattrapent trompe peu
probable nous n'avons même pas besoin de
cet état
c'est en attaque pour en aurait été
content de l'avoir mais il ya maintenant
une bonne probabilité que quand on
remporte mais tout se joue un tout petit
nombre de votes
on aimerait que cet état reste une
possibilité mais entre temps nous
remportons la pennsylvanie qui une
marche d'une énorme âge
[Applaudissements]
imaginez nous avons nous avons une
avance de six cent quatre-vingt dix
mille votes en pennsylvanie donc ce
n'est même pas m ce n'est même pas serré
on était content et donc il est presque
impossible qui n'est pas très intéressé
vannes et ils sont pauvres
donc on va probablement le remporter
nous gagnons nous allons remporter le
michigan
nous sommes en tête j'ai regardé les
chiffres et je le suis dit c'est
beaucoup avec presque un an avant
c'était presque 300 mille votes
65% des voix ont été comptés nous
gagnons oh oui je continue aussi mais il
nous avons même pas besoin de tous ses
états puisque nous avons nous avons
remporté le texte j'ai parlé avec le
gouverneur du texas il y à peu et il m'a
appelé pour me féliciter davout de
l'avoir emporté au texte offre
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas encore fini
totalement depuis y ait des voix mais il
n'y a pas moyen que bada nous rattrape
et il m'a dit qu'est ce qui se passe je
n'ai jamais vu une chose pareille
et je vous dit quelque chose personne
n'a jamais vu une chose pareille
nous avons gagné avec 80 1% des voix au
michigan
donc quand vous prenez en compte ces
trois états avec tous les autres nous
avons eu il
une belle soirée quand vous voyez tous
les états où nous l'avons remporté ce
soir et les marges aussi ce n'est pas
comme si on gagne de peu non on a
remporté des états entiers
maintenant qu'est ce qui arrive aux
élections cette année lit on
des déclarations qui disent des choses
contradictoires qui disent ils savaient
qu'ils pouvaient ils ne pouvaient pas
gagner
donc allons devant les tribunaux et
c'est ce que je dis depuis que j'étais
au courant de cela que nous gagnons ou
pas on va devoir passer devant les
tribunaux au florida nous avons une
belle victoire
tech s'associent pour jeudi à ohio
c'est un grand homme d'état un état que
j'adore nous avons gagné avec wii vers 1
% presque 500 mille voix en carreaux
bien janot nous avons remporté une belle
victoire
nous avons une avance de 60 16 mille
votes et il reste presque puis de voix à
dépouiller et tout d'un coup tout s'est
arrêté
c'est une fraude contre le public
américain cela m notre pays dans
l'embarras nous nous apprêtions à gagner
ces élections et nous avons
sélection pour être franche ouest france
donc notre but maintenant est de
s'assurer de l'intégrité de ces
élections pour le bien de notre pays et
il s'agit d'une fraude contre notre pays
nous voulons que la loi soit appliquée
comme il se doit
donc nous allons passer devant le
tribunal suprême des etats unis
on veut que tout tout ça s'arrête on ne
veut pas qu'ils trouvent des désirs non
comptés à 4 l'humeur temps et qui lui
qui déjà qu'ils ajoutent à la liste
pour moi c'est un moment très triste
mais nous allons remporter ces élections
et en ce qui me concerne nous les avons
déjà gagné
donc j'aimerais vous remercier qui
j'aimerais remercier tous ceux qui nous
avons tous ceux qui nous ont soutenus ou
travaillent avec nous et monsieur le
vice président à vous la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président je me voir à vous
pour remercier les millions d'américains
qui ont déjà exprimé de vote pour encore
quatre ans de monsieur dans un trou de 2
puis l'on continue nous restons
vigilants comme le président a dit le
droit de voter a été au centre de notre
démocratie depuis que ce pays a été
fondé
donc nous allons protéger l'intégrité du
vote je crois de tout mon coeur coeur
avec les mange extraordinaire que
monsieur le président a eu dans les
états qui vient de décrire et avec la
façon danser ce mouvement a été dansé
pour rendre pour rendre la gloire aux
états unis avec tout cela je crois que
nous sommes en bon chemin pour les
victoires et que nous allons rendre la
loi ou aux états unis
avant de
sont les derniers mots de mike pence